happy I've got some graham crackers What
would a dietitian do with these oh you
are going to love my apple pie bites
let's do it okay these could not be
simpler so they start with graham
crackers and I'm actually obsessed with
graham crackers I know they're called a
cracker but they're kind of like a
cookie cracker they're super sweet
they've got a nice little hint of
sweetness but not too aggressively sweet
and they're actually naturally low in
sugar just two grams per square so
separate those out and I'm going to take
a big dollop of some Greek yogurt a
little chopped Apple a little sprinkle
of cinnamon and pecan for crunch we got
protein in the Greek yogurt fiber in our
apples and healthy fats in our pecans
all in a really delicious fun little
bite